Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table !",
l'émission qui cuisine
les personnalités.
Aujourd'hui, nous recevons
Fadila Khattabi.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être venue.
Avec moi,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour.
-Vous êtes ministre
déléguée chargée
des Personnes handicapées.
Vous avez été nommée à l'occasion
du dernier remaniement.
Professeur d'anglais à l'origine,
vous vous lancez
en politique à l'âge de 40 ans
au Parti Socialiste puis vous êtes
tentée par l'aventure En Marche.
Députée depuis 2017,
vous avez occupé
dès 2020 le poste
de présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée.
Vous avez eu à gérer la réforme
des retraites
ou la proposition de loi
du groupe LIOT pour abroger
la réforme des retraites.
Vous avez invité les députés
à ouvrir leurs chakras
et à remettre la mosquée
au milieu du bled,
deux punchlines devenues cultes
pour les afficionados du Parlement.
Vous ne reniez rien
de vos origines
algériennes.
Vous avez plutôt décidé
de nous envoyer des clins d'oeil
à l'Italie et à l'Angleterre.
-Exactement, au menu,
on a des lasagnes,
mais à quoi ?
Mystère.
Et un dessert mythique, une île
flottante à la crème anglaise.
-Dans Le dessous
des plats, reportage
dans une chocolaterie
modèle et éthique
qui emploie du personnel
handicapé
et respecte
les petits producteurs.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
la précarité alimentaire
s'aggrave.
15 % des Français ont du mal
à faire trois repas par jour.
Nous avons suivi Amina,
qui galère.
-On passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Fadila Khattabi,
comme l'ADN, les lasagnes,
avec leurs couches,
disent beaucoup de nous.
Au fromage et à la pâte phyllo,
ce sont les sou-beureg,
ces lasagnes arméniennes,
au poulet et safran, façon paella,
des lasagnes ibériques,
les kayseri yaglamasi
sont les lasagnes turques,
au pain et au yaourt, au boeuf
et à la sauce tomates,
ce sont les bolognaises,
et il y a les vôtres,
façon Khattabi,
qui racontent
votre vie.
Le ton de la Méditerranée,
les poivrons rouges,
c'est l'Algérie,
la béchamel et le gruyère,
la France des terroirs,
les courgettes,
c'est pour être végétarien,
et cette sauce arrabiata,
sauce pimentée italienne
que vous voulez
abondante.
"Arrabiata" signifie "en colère".
C'est tout vous.
La citoyenne,
la députée indignée !
On n'a trouvé personne
pour faire ces lasagnes,
alors on va en déguster
des classiques.
J'espère que vous allez
vous en remettre.
-En tout cas, ça sent très bon.
C'est déjà pas mal.
-C'est quoi, les lasagnes
façon Khattabi ?
-C'est un plat...
J'adore, en fait, déjà,
faire la cuisine,
et j'adore revisiter les plats,
les recettes.
Et là, en fait, ce sont des lasagnes
au thon avec des poivrons rouges,
que je fais revenir à l'huile
d'olive avec des oignons,
je mets de la sauce arrabiata.
J'ai omis de dire
que des câpres, avec le thon,
ça se marie très bien.
-Pour relever.
-Pour relever les lasagnes,
et cette sauce béchamel,
qui apporte aussi sa spécificité,
sa douceur, etc., par rapport
à l'arrabiata, qui est épicée.
Bref, mes enfants adorent
ce plat.
-C'est pour eux ?
C'est une dédicace
à vos enfants ?
-Un peu un clin d'oeil,
parce qu'en fait,
je tenais absolument,
comme j'étais extrêmement occupée
tout au long
de ces 20 dernières années,
à faire la cuisine
le week-end et à avoir mes enfants
autour de moi, toute ma famille.
Souvent, je leur disais :
"Qu'est-ce que vous voulez manger ?"
Très souvent, c'était les lasagnes.
-Ils ont quel âge,
vos enfants, maintenant ?
-Ils sont grands.
Mon fils a 32
et ma fille a 25.
Quand j'ai commencé la politique,
ils avaient 12 et 5 ans.
Donc je tenais absolument
à faire en sorte
de répondre à leurs attentes,
et ils adorent
bien manger des bons produits.
-Ces lasagnes Khattabi
qui vont être
un jour déposées,
c'est la recette de votre maman,
d'un restaurant d'Algérie ?
C'est vous qui l'avez
complètement imaginée,
en transe dans votre cuisine ?
-Ah oui, en colère !
-Oui, indignée !
Arrabiata !
-En fait,
déjà, j'adore la cuisine relevée,
donc inutile de vous dire
que j'ai vécu une année
en Angleterre, j'ai souffert.
-La purge, oui.
-Et en plus,
j'adore les produits frais,
courgettes...
J'adore le poivron rouge.
Quand je prépare,
j'en croque systématiquement.
Cru, je trouve ça très bon.
En fait, c'est une recette
complètement revisitée
façon Fadila Khattabi.
-C'est vous qui faites
la sauce arrabiata
et la béchamel ?
-Oui, je prépare.
La sauce arrabiata,
il en existe toute préparée,
mais j'apporte ma touche...
-C'est une sauce tomate
un peu pimentée.
-Oui, mais il y en a qui sont
très bien préparées.
-Avec du piment ?
-Oui.
Je peux rajouter
un peu d'épices, du poivre,
j'accentue le côté un peu épicé
de l'arrabiata,
et tout ça est doux
avec la salade,
parce que j'adore
manger des lasagnes
avec une salade, si possible
laitue ou feuille de chêne
avec une petite vinaigrette,
huile d'olive...
-C'est pour se donner
bonne conscience.
-Non, parce qu'il y a
de l'huile d'olive,
de l'échalotte, du persil...
-On va les goûter, non ?
-Voilà, dites-nous ce que
vous pensez de ces lasagnes
qui sont concurrentes,
des lasagnes bolognaise,
à la viande de boeuf.
C'est quand même bon.
-Elles sont au thon.
-Celles-ci sont au thon.
Je vois qu'il y a de...
Elles sont revisitées.
Il y a des olives.
-Oui.
-Des olives noires.
-Il y a beaucoup de sauce tomate.
-Il y a des câpres.
Pour l'histoire, au début,
il voulait pas faire
des lasagnes Khattabi,
mais il s'est un peu inspiré.
-C'est pas mal.
-C'est pas assez relevé
pour vous ?
-Pas assez à mon goût,
mais c'est pas mal.
Même mes enfants apprécieraient.
-En attendant,
trois choses
à savoir pour réussir
ces lasagnes.
-Oui.
Celles-ci sont au thon.
Moi, je préconise toujours
un mélange veau-boeuf
et je rajoute un peu
de pancetta pour apporter
du goût et du moelleux.
Des belles tomates
italiennes en boîte.
Souvent, on n'est pas
dans la saison.
N'hésitez pas à acheter
des boîtes de tomates pelées.
Carottes, céleri,
oignons, thym,
et faire mijoter
cette sauce très longtemps.
La béchamel ne doit pas
être trop compacte.
Il faut qu'elle soit fluide.
Beurre, farine, lait
et une pincée de muscade.
La facilité,
ce sont les pâtes
précuites qui vont cuire
avec le liquide des sauces.
Moi, je préfère les vraies pâtes
fraîches de lasagnes.
On les met dans l'eau
une à deux minutes,
on les met dans le plat
et on accumule les couches,
béchamel, sauce tomate,
et on finit par le gratin,
parmesan et gruyère.
-On fait gratiner
au four ?
-Il faut que ce soit gratiné.
-Je vous entendais
dire en loge
que c'est meilleur le lendemain.
-Tous les plats en sauce,
à base de cause tomate,
sont toujours meilleurs
le lendemain,
quand ça a bien macéré.
C'est plus relevé et juteux.
-Vous nous disiez que vos enfants
ne mangent que ces lasagnes
parce que ce sont
les meilleures du monde,
disiez-vous
avec modestie
ou fausse modestie.
Les lasagnes classiques,
vous n'en mangez jamais ?
-Non, mes enfants...
-Et vous ne les préparez jamais.
-Non, jamais.
Mes enfants
ont probablement dépassé
le maître, maintenant.
Mon fils les prépare
merveilleusement bien.
-La même recette ?
-Oui.
Ma fille aussi.
-Ca se transmet.
-Pas plus tard
que le week-end dernier,
ma fille en a préparé pour sa mamie,
qu'elle a trouvées superbes.
-C'est un clin d'oeil
à l'Italie ?
-J'adore l'Italie.
J'adore voyager
et j'ai une affection particulière
pour les pays du sud.
Mais j'adore voyager.
L'Italie est un très beau pays
avec une richesse culturelle...
-Il y a d'autres
plats italiens
que vous préparez ?
-Des pizzas, tout simple.
Oui, je la fais.
Quand j'ai du temps,
je peux préparer la pâte.
Moi, je suis plutôt poissons,
alors je mets du saumon,
des anchois, des câpres,
des olives...
-Les câpres, toujours.
-Oui, j'adore.
-Comme les lasagnes,
chaque pays a sa pizza.
La mode à Paris,
c'est les pizzas libanaises.
Pizzas turques...
-Elles sont revisitées.
-On voit que vous êtes fusion.
C'est le mélange
entre vos deux cultures,
dans ces lasagnes.
Il y a
d'autres plats où vous fusionnez
vos deux cultures ?
Vous faites
un boeuf bourguignon...
Ils parlent en même temps.
-Revisitées...
Je préfère peut-être plus
la blanquette de veau.
Ca, j'adore.
-Quelle est
la touche algérienne ?
-C'est toujours le côté
un peu relevé.
-Oui...
-Les épices.
-C'est ça, les épices.
Je mets
champignons,
un peu de carottes...
Je respecte...
-Ras el-hanout dans la blanquette ?
-Ah non...
-Ca se marie
pas très bien.
-Non.
Je sais quand même
marier les épices.
Un peu de poivre,
mais pas de ras el-hanout.
-Parce que vous,
vous avez des origines algériennes.
Vos parents sont
algériens.
Vous êtes née à Montbéliard.
Est-ce que vous avez été baignée
dans cette culture ?
Culture culinaire,
je veux dire.
Est-ce que vos parents
faisaient souvent
des plats classiques
comme le couscous ou le tajine ?
-Oui,
j'ai été élevée
dans cette cuisine-là.
Nous étions en plus neuf enfants.
Maman préparait bien sûr
le couscous,
mais pas que.
Elle faisait
des tajines,
la chorba.
D'ailleurs, vous avez accueilli
un député qui est né
en Algérie
et qui avait choisi
la chorba.
-Cette fameuse soupe
qu'on mange au Ramadan.
-Voilà, on la mange
avec du pain fait maison,
de la galette,
et puis de la coriandre.
Il faut que la soupe
soit parfumée.
Personnellement, j'y mets aussi
de la menthe et de la coriandre.
Oui, bien sûr, j'ai été baignée
dans cette cuisine-là.
En même temps,
je suis née en France
et comme j'aime
la cuisine,
je cuisine aussi
les plats traditionnels
français comme...
-Vous avez
perpétué ça
avec vos enfants ?
Vous leur faites du couscous ?
-Oui.
Le couscous, c'est long à faire.
-Oui, c'est long.
-Votre maman, pour neuf,
faire du couscous pour neuf...
-Elle le faisait.
Elle le faisait.
C'était une génération aussi
qui aimait beaucoup cuisiner
pour les enfants.
Comme on grandissait,
tous ados...
Ca mange !
Donc bercés, effectivement,
avec le couscous.
J'aime aussi le couscous au lait.
On a été élevés
avec ça.
-C'est quoi ?
-Un couscous
avec du lait
que vous faites chauffer
et un peu de sel, j'adore ça.
-Vous buvez le lait à côté ?
-Non.
-Mélangé dans la semoule ?
-La semoule est cuite
comme pour un couscous
traditionnel,
et après,
vous faites chauffer
dans une casserole du lait,
vous mettez le lait
dans le couscous, donc c'est un plat
chaud, et...
Un peu de sel et c'est super bon.
Nous, on adore ça.
-Sans légumes ?
-J'adore ça !
-Sans viande ?
-Je pensais que c'était un dessert
avec du sucre et de la cannelle,
pour faire un gâteau de semoule.
-Oui, il y en a qui en mettent,
mais le raisin dans le couscous,
c'est pas mon truc.
-Vous dites que vous préférez
le poisson à la viande.
C'est un goût personnel
ou c'est à cause du climat ou...
-Non,
pas du tout, je préfère le poisson.
-Pour le bien-être animal ?
-Non, je suis plutôt poisson,
et j'aime bien les viandes blanches.
J'aime bien le veau...
-Le poulet ?
-Le poulet,
j'aime surtout la pintade,
parce que je trouve
que la viande est
plus fine.
J'adore... J'aime pas trop
les abats, mais j'adore
le foie de canard
qui est très bon
avec une sauce
vinaigrette
à la framboise,
échalotes, persil,
servi avec une salade...
-Le gésier de canard aussi.
-Oui.
C'est très très bon.
J'essaie de revisiter les choses,
mais j'aime la cuisine aussi
bien française, donc en fait,
ma table est un peu internationale.
C'est très varié.
Evidemment, les gens ont tendance
à avoir des préjugés.
"On va manger un bon couscous
chez toi."
Je fais pas que le couscous...
Il y a pas que ça.
J'adore les cailles au raisin,
par exemple.
J'adore la cuisine.
Je suis frustrée,
parce que le temps me manque
depuis que je suis députée.
J'ai peu de temps pour cuisiner.
-Vous avez d'autres recettes ?
Vous nous parliez de blanquette.
Il y a d'autres plats
qui vous reviennent
et que vous faites ?
-Par exemple, j'adore
ce qu'on fait...
Le tajine aux pruneaux.
C'est vrai
que les plats sucrés,
c'est pas mon fort, au niveau goût,
mais ce plat,
je l'aime particulièrement.
Normalement,
on le mange
comme ça.
Moi, je le sers aussi
avec un couscous.
Et le tajine aux pruneaux
avec une sauce...
Là, pour le coup,
il y a
les épices,
du cumin, de la cannelle.
-Du gingembre ?
-Oui, du ras el-hanout et tout...
Et c'est très, très bon.
Je revisite avec le couscous.
Certains disent
qu'on ne sert pas avec le couscous,
moi si, comme je pourrais servir
le tajine
aux pruneaux avec du riz
que mes enfants aiment.
-La fusion
dont vous parliez.
-Quand la ministre
rentre le soir, harassée
par sa journée de boulot,
qu'est-ce qu'elle aime se préparer
en peu de temps pour se régaler ?
-J'ai peu de temps
pour cuisiner.
Généralement, on nous sert...
On m'envoie mon plat
dans mon appartement
ou au bureau.
Je pense
qu'ils doivent faire
attention à la ligne des ministres.
C'est plutôt salade,
salade de fruits...
Voilà...
C'est très "végétarien".
Quand même,
il y a une viande à midi...
-Vous avez donné des consignes
au ministère ?
-Pas vraiment.
Quand je reçois des personnes
au ministère,
je suis embarrassée
d'avoir un dessert différent
de celui
de mes invités
qui ont une pâtisserie
et moi, juste la salade de fruits
toujours
très bien décorée,
préparée avec beaucoup d'attention
et d'amour, je suppose et...
Je pense qu'ils doivent penser
qu'il faut faire attention.
-Vous aimeriez la pâtisserie ?
-Parfois, pourquoi pas.
-Ils vous ont mis au régime.
-Mais il faut faire attention.
Je faisais beaucoup de sport
avant d'être députée.
Depuis que je suis députée,
j'ai moins le temps.
J'ai pris mon abonnement
dans une salle.
Je vais essayer
de faire du sport.
Il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on mange :
manger,
mais avec modération.
-Aujourd'hui, tout le monde fait
attention à ce qu'il consomme.
Certains mangent pas ou moins
de viande, plus de légumineuses,
du bio, du local...
Est-ce que vous faites attention
à ce que vous consommez,
à savoir d'où viennent les produits,
qui les a cultivés ?
-Oui, je fais quand même attention,
bien sûr.
Essayer de choisir
des bons produits,
des produits frais.
L'idéal, c'est d'aller au marché,
mais je n'ai pas le temps,
et d'avoir aussi une variété
dans les légumes.
J'avoue que mes enfants,
je les ai habitués ainsi.
Ils aiment tout.
Il faut les habituer
dès qu'ils sont très jeunes
pour aimer les légumes.
Ils mangent des épinards,
ils mangent de tout.
C'est important de bien manger.
C'est une question aussi de santé,
de santé publique.
On sent aujourd'hui
qu'on a beaucoup de jeunes
en situation d'obésité.
Ils font moins
de sport,
ils sont plutôt
sur leur tablette.
Il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on mange.
Il faut aussi,
pas la quantité,
mais une certaine qualité.
Je voyage un petit peu.
J'ai vu, par exemple, à New York...
La situation est
quand même très grave.
-Préoccupante.
-Très préoccupante,
avec des maladies cardiovasculaires,
du diabète,
donc il faut faire
attention
à ce qu'on mange.
-Jamais de produits
transformés, chez vous ?
-Très peu,
même si on a pas toujours le choix.
J'essaye
d'acheter des produits frais.
-J'imagine
que vous avez fait
quand même des marchés
quand vous étiez en campagne
pour les législatives.
-Oui, bien sûr.
J'allais sur les marchés.
D'ailleurs,
sur ma circonscription,
il y a un très beau marché
le dimanche
avec une variété d'exposants,
de bons produits,
de légumes, etc.
Et plus, il y a
une certaine chaleur humaine
dans les marchés,
j'aime cela.
Mais quand on travaille
et qu'on est sur Paris,
c'est compliqué
de faire les marchés,
désormais,
sur ma circonscription,
dans laquelle j'essaie
quand même de me rendre.
-On vous a demandé
de choisir un vin,
mais vous ne buvez pas vin.
Je vais déjà vous dire
ce que c'est.
C'est un côte-de-nuits,
c'est un marsannay.
Là, on se trouve au commencement
de la route des grands crus.
C'est le nord de la Côte-d'Or.
C'est un millésime 2021.
C'est un cépage de pinot noir,
bien sûr,
et c'est élevé en cuve inox
10 à 12 mois.
La particularité de ce marsannay,
c'est que c'est un vin
qui est assez vif et robuste
parce que dans le sol,
il y a pas mal de fer.
Il a une robe couleur rubis
et un nez assez floral.
C'est vraiment
sa particularité.
Pourquoi vous nous avez
choisi du vin,
alors que vous n'en...
Il y a une histoire
autour de ce vin ?
-Déjà, comme vous le savez,
on est en Bourgogne,
c'est quand même
la région du vin,
et puis pour tout vous dire,
j'ai demandé
à François Patriat :
"Je participe
à une émission..."
-Vous êtes
de la même circonscription.
-Oui, il est sénateur
de la Côte-d'Or,
et moi, j'étais députée
de la 3e circonscription.
Je voulais absolument que ce soit
un vin de ma circonscription.
Quand vous dites
la Côte-d'Or,
les gens pensent au vin,
mais moi, j'ai pas la côte,
j'ai le début de la côte.
Si vous dites 3e circonscription
de Côte-d'Or,
ça parle pas, mais si vous dites
"j'ai Marsannay-la-Côte",
ça parle.
-Ca prend une autre dimension.
-Voilà, tout de suite :
"Ah oui, la Côte-d'Or !
Ah oui, la côte !"
Donc j'ai demandé à François,
il m'a dit :
"Un très bon marsannay,
il faut y aller."
Lui, c'est un expert
dans ce domaine.
Donc voilà,
c'était un clin d'oeil...
-A François Patriat.
-...à François Patriat, avec qui,
bien sûr, j'ai mené
tous les combats politiques
depuis 2004,
puisque c'est lui qui m'a mise
sur la liste en 2004.
Mon premier mandat commence
aux régionales de 2004.
Et puis ensuite,
il m'a nommée vice-présidente
lors du 2e mandat,
en charge de l'emploi,
de la formation.
J'avais le 2e portefeuille
de la région.
-Donc on lève notre verre
à François Patriat !
-Voilà.
Merci, François.
-On a vu
que vous vous y connaissiez bien
en cuisine.
On va voir
si vous êtes incollable.
-Vous aimez bien
ce qui est pimenté.
Justement, une des sauces totems
du Maghreb, c'est la harissa.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
concernant cette sauce pimentée
sont vraies ?
Le piment débarque en Tunisie
au 16e siècle.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Peut-être, je dirais oui.
-Oui, exactement...
-Parce que la harissa
vient de Tunisie.
-...par l'Espagne,
les conquistadors.
Dans la composition
de la harissa,
on trouve aussi du gingembre.
-Je dis non.
-Faux, oui.
Il y a du carvi, de la coriandre,
mais pas de gingembre.
C : en 2015, Time Magazine,
le grand magazine américain,
a classé la harissa
parmi les 5 aliments du monde
les plus sains.
Vrai ou faux ?
Il y a un piège.
-J'aurais tendance à dire,
ça déménage,
mais c'est pas si sain que ça,
quand on mange trop épicé,
mais je vais dire oui.
-Alors oui,
mais pas parmi les 5,
parmi les 50.
-Ah ! C'est pas mal.
-50 aliments du monde entier,
c'est pas mal.
Mais les 5,
votre remarque était juste.
Et ceux qui supportent pas
le piment...
-Il faut faire attention
et penser à son estomac.
-Et D : un chef français
a osé faire un sorbet
framboise/harissa.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Aujourd'hui, la cuisine
est tellement colorée
que j'ai envie de dire vrai.
-Vous avez raison.
C'est Alexandre Mazzia
qui a osé ce petit mélange
exotique et incongru,
la framboise
dopée à la harissa.
Bravo.
-Ca doit être pas mal.
Il doit être comme moi,
il aime le mélange
des cultures.
-Autre quiz.
Une des spécialités de votre fief
politique, la Côte-d'Or,
est le pain d'épices.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
sont vraies ?
Avec Dijon,
Rennes est une autre capitale
du pain d'épices.
Vrai ou faux ?
Rennes.
-Je dirais... faux.
-Faux. Pas du tout.
Le miel
du pain d'épices dijonnais
est le miel de châtaignier.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Pas que. Pas que.
Il y a différents miels.
J'ai visité en plus l'atelier
où on fabrique
le pain d'épices à Dijon,
Mulot & Petitjean,
et pas que. En tout cas,
c'est ce que la...
-C'est même faux.
C'est l'acacia.
-Voilà. Donc voilà.
Donc j'avais raison.
-Vous avez raison, allez.
Vous aimez pas perdre !
Ils rient.
La nonnette de Dijon
est fourrée traditionnellement
avec de la confiture d'oranges.
-Traditionnellement ? Euh...
Oui, mais il y a aussi
aujourd'hui
de la nonnette à la framboise,
au cassis...
-Vrai. Bravo.
-La nonnette,
c'est un petit pain d'épices.
-Oui, oui,
Ils ont fait évoluer
certains produits,
et la nonnette marche très bien,
avec cette confiture.
Pour un quatre-heures avec un thé
à la menthe, c'est sympa.
-L'ours Prosper
est la mascotte
de la marque
du pain d'épices Fossier.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Je dirais vrai.
-Eh ben c'est faux.
-Vous vous souvenez pas ?
-Si, si.
-C'était la marque Vandamme.
-Ah oui !
C'est vrai !
Cet ours, oui !
-C'est votre jeunesse, ça !
-Oui !
J'ai pas réfléchi,
j'ai répondu
de manière spontanée.
-Les pains d'épices Fossier,
personne ne connaît.
-Tout à fait.
Non mais vraiment, Prosper...
-C'est souvent
autour de la table
que les langues se délient,
qu'il y a des deals politiques.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
On vous a demandé
de réfléchir
à une anecdote politique
autour d'un repas.
Est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à nous livrer ?
-Oui. En fait,
c'est le dernier repas
que j'ai pris
à l'Assemblée nationale,
24 heures avant ma nomination
comme ministre déléguée
aux Personnes
en situation de handicap.
J'ai voulu marquer la fin
d'une session parlementaire
qui a été quand même
très riche,
mouvementée, dense,
donc j'ai voulu remercier
toutes mes équipes
pour leur engagement
à mes côtés
pendant cette période
qui fut quand même
ô combien complexe.
Et donc, nous étions
au restaurant
à l'Assemblée nationale,
et je disais :
"Ecoutez, je suis ravie
de pouvoir poursuivre,
"je suis heureuse
de ma fonction de présidente."
Ils étaient là : "On est contents
de repartir avec vous."
J'ai dit : "L'année qui va venir
va être dense."
On fixait
les derniers rendez-vous
d'audition de ministres,
d'audition
de personnalités, etc.
Et tous étaient là :
"Vraiment, on est ravis.
L'année a été difficile,
"mais on est prêts
à repartir avec vous."
Et puis 24 heures après...
Oui, 24 heures après,
le jeudi 20 juillet,
aux alentours de midi,
j'étais en train
de faire les derniers paraphes,
seule, dans mon bureau.
On parlait du remaniement
à la télé.
On attendait depuis des semaines
et je me disais :
"Ca va tomber ce soir !
"Ca va tomber ce soir !"
Tout à coup, mon collaborateur tape
et entre timidement.
Il me dit :
"Madame la présidente,
"la Première ministre
essaie désespérément
"de vous joindre."
Il me dit : "Là,
j'ai le secrétariat particulier."
Je dis : "D'accord.
Je vais rappeler."
Donc, je cherche mon téléphone,
car je n'étais pas du tout à côté...
-Vous n'attendiez pas
l'appel de Matignon.
-Je n'attendais
aucune nouvelle,
aucun message
de la part de Matignon.
Donc, je fouille
dans mon sac,
je regarde mon téléphone
et je dis :
"Ah oui..."
-"Appel en absence :
"Elisabeth Borne."
-Voilà, Elisabeth Borne,
"le secrétariat particulier
de Matignon...
Donc, je rappelle
le secrétariat.
On me dit : "La Première ministre
essaie de vous joindre."
Et je dis...
Donc, on me la passe,
et elle me dit :
"Bonjour, Fadila.
Tu vas bien ?"
"Oui, je vais bien, chère Elisabeth.
Et toi ?"
Elle me dit :
"Je vais bien."
Et puis, il y a
un blanc d'une seconde.
"Bon, j'ai quelque chose
"à te proposer."
J'avoue que c'est
le grand blanc pour moi.
"J'aimerais
que tu sois ministre déléguée
"en charge des Personnes
en situation de handicap."
Et, deux ou trois secondes après,
je lui dis : "Mais Elisabeth,
moi, j'ai rien demandé."
Elle me dit : "Bah justement,
même si tu n'as rien demandé,
"on a quand même pensé
à toi."
Et effectivement,
je n'attendais pas
cette nomination...
-Mais vous acceptez avec plaisir ?
-Oui, parce qu'en plus...
Je m'y attendais pas,
car de par mon histoire personnelle,
j'étais pas prédestinée
à être députée,
ni présidente de commission,
encore moins ministre.
Donc, quand elle me fait
cette proposition,
déjà, je suis très honorée
de sa confiance
et de celle du président,
qui m'offre quand même
un beau portefeuille,
celui des Personnes
en situation de handicap,
où les défis
sont très, très importants.
Elle me dit :
"Je serais très, très, très heureuse
"que tu acceptes."
Vous avez trois secondes
pour répondre
et je lui dis :
"J'accepte, Elisabeth.
Je suis très, très honorée.
"Merci."
Et elle dit : "Bon, très bien."
Elle raccroche,
et puis là,
tout de suite,
je me dis : "Waouh."
Elle rit.
Le premier
que j'ai appelé,
c'est quand même mon époux...
-Pour le prévenir.
-Oui, pour le prévenir.
-"Je vais être ministre."
-Ensuite, j'ai appelé
mes deux enfants.
Ma fille était
très heureuse pour moi,
mon fils...
Il me surprotège un peu.
Il m'a dit : "Mais tu sais,
maman, c'est compliqué.
"Tu vas prendre des coups."
Ca fait partie
de l'engagement politique...
-"On va plus te voir",
ils ne vous l'ont pas dit ?
-Un peu, mais il a fait sa vie.
Il n'est plus à la maison.
Ma fille était très heureuse,
et ensuite,
j'ai appelé mon suppléant,
Philippe Frei.
Lui, il déjeunait
avec son fils,
quand il a vu mon appel...
-Il est donc devenu député
à votre place.
-Tout à coup...
Je devais repartir, en fait.
Mon chauffeur m'attendait
en bas,
la valise était dans la voiture,
on repartait
sur Dijon,
alors que 24 heures avant,
je disais :
"Ca va être le break,
"10 jours encore
en circonscription..."
-Et vous avez dû tout annuler.
Les plans ont changé.
-Voilà.
Elle me dit : "Je vous attends."
Je l'avais zappée.
Je lui dis :
"Je ne pars plus."
"Je pense avoir deviné",
me répond-elle.
-On va donc parler
de votre ministère, maintenant,
de votre engagement,
à travers le chocolat.
Tout savoir pour transformer
la fève en tablette,
un apprentissage qui est minutieux
pour des personnes handicapées.
C'est Le dessous des plats.
-Produire
du chocolat éthique
avec des personnes handicapées
tout en respectant la planète
et les producteurs
du Cameroun,
c'est le sacré pari tenu
par Févier d'Or,
entreprise familiale
qui a ouvert ses portes
à nos journalistes Hélène Bonduelle
et Pierre-Yves Deheuninck.
Musique légère
-Ici, vous êtes
dans une chocolaterie
artisanale, familiale,
qui a la spécificité
de maîtriser
tout le process de fabrication
du chocolat,
depuis la culture du cacao
jusqu'au produit fini,
sans intermédiaire.
-Pour Nadine Abondo,
franco-camerounaise,
le chocolat,
c'est une histoire de famille :
trois générations
de production de cacao.
-Vous avez d'abord
en face de vous
la cultivatrice du cacao
que vous consommez.
Dès samedi,
je suis dans les plantations
pour récolter le cacao.
-Au-delà du cacao,
dans son entreprise,
Nadine cultive aussi
la différence.
-Pendant que Thomas
fait les tablettes,
vous, vous faites quoi ?
-Je pèse.
-Ah, vous, vous pesez.
OK, Ca, c'est bon ?
-Oui.
-OK, si ça c'est bon,
ça veut dire que ça doit aller
dans la chambre froide.
-Ici, 15 des 17 salariés
sont en situation de handicap,
handicap physique
ou mental.
-Je suis pas médecin,
je peux pas soigner.
Par contre, oui,
je peux insérer.
Je peux permettre
à mon collaborateur
d'avoir un vrai contrat
de travail, un CDI.
Ici, tous les collaborateurs
sont en CDI.
-La cheffe d'entreprise
a composé les équipes
en fonction des capacités
de chacun.
Un équilibre à trouver
entre la valorisation
des compétences...
-Si vous faites des tablettes
qui n'ont pas le bon poids,
on ne peut pas
les emballer.
-...et l'exigence
d'un chocolat haut de gamme.
-La difficulté,
c'est donc ça :
c'est de pouvoir challenger
une entreprise,
qui est de droit commun,
dans un secteur concurrentiel
comme le nôtre,
tout en employant des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Et puis, de toute façon,
je les prépare aussi à entrer
dans un milieu
qui sera moins protégé.
Vous aurez compris qu'ici,
je vais dire des choses
d'une certaine manière.
Ailleurs, ça sera pas comme ça.
-Dans n'importe quel métier
que vous faites,
ils accompagnent pas.
-Moi, quand je suis arrivé ici,
je me suis dit :
"Voilà, c'est un travail
où t'as un vrai salaire,
"qui te permet d'avoir des projets
pour plus tard dans la vie."
Moi, maintenant,
grâce à madame Abondo
et grâce à ici,
j'ai un foyer d'hébergement.
-La cheffe d'entreprise
s'engage aussi en amont.
Elle garantit un salaire minimum
à chaque producteur camerounais
avec lequel elle travaille.
-J'ai été très touché
par ce jeune handicapé
qui parle d'accompagnement.
C'est vraiment le mot-clé
quand on est patron
et qu'on doit essayer d'insérer
ces populations vulnérables ?
-Oui, là, nous avons
un très bel exemple de réussite.
Nul n'est inemployable,
et les personnes
en situation de handicap
peuvent s'insérer
professionnellement,
mais parfois,
il faut un accompagnement
individualisé...
-Ca veut dire quoi,
"accompagnement individualisé",
dans la vie de l'entrepreneur
et du salarié ?
-Il faut dire aux chefs d'entreprise
que cela est possible,
qu'en adaptant
le poste de travail,
la personne est capable
d'assumer, effectivement,
tel ou tel métier.
On a dans cette chocolaterie
des personnes
en situation de handicap,
qui travaillent,
qui gagnent leur vie,
qui souhaitent travailler.
Depuis que je suis ministre,
j'ai reçu énormément
de courriers,
de messages pour me dire :
"Madame, faites en sorte
qu'on respecte nos droits
"d'aller à l'école, d'accéder
à la santé et de travailler."
-Elles sont beaucoup
plus touchées par le chômage,
14 % contre 7 %
dans la population active.
-Pas tout à fait 14.
En 2019, le taux de chômage
des personnes en situation
de handicap était de 19 %.
Aujourd'hui, grâce à la politique
volontariste que nous menons,
et c'était aussi également
Mme la Première ministre
qui était ministre du Travail
et avec Olivier Dussopt,
leur situation s'est améliorée.
Nous étions à 19 %,
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 12 %.
Cela reste au-delà
de la moyenne nationale,
donc il faut renforcer
l'accompagnement.
-Il faut inciter les entreprises...
-Sensibiliser
les chefs d'entreprise.
-Ce sont des aides financières
ou faut-il renforcer les quotas ?
-Il y a déjà des aides financières
pour adapter le poste
et accompagner l'entreprise,
mais parfois,
il faut sensibiliser
les chefs d'entreprise
qui ne savent pas comment faire.
Pour ce faire...
-"Je ne sais pas comment faire",
"je ne sais pas
si c'est la bonne personne".
-Justement, le projet de loi
a été voté cette semaine,
porté par Olivier Dussopt et,
vraiment,
je le remercie d'avoir inséré
deux articles qui concernent
l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap pour faire en sorte
que leurs droits soient respectés.
Une personne qui travaille
dans un ESAT
n'avait pas droit
à la prime transport,
n'avait pas le droit de faire grève,
ce qui est absolument scandaleux.
Donc, on a aligné
les droits des salariés handicapés
sur les droits des autres salariés
et en même temps,
grâce à France travail,
il y a un travail de collaboration
entre Pôle emploi
et Cap emploi,
qui ont des experts
qui accompagnent les personnes
en situation de handicap
et ce travail collaboratif
permet de travailler le projet
de la personne handicapée
et de l'accompagner
dans ce qu'elle souhaite faire.
Il faut répondre
aux besoins de la personne
et écouter la personne.
Moi, les personnes me disent :
"Madame, écoutez-nous.
Faites respecter nos droits
"et nous avons des choix
qu'on souhaiterait voir respectés."
Donc, c'est tout cela.
-On voit dans ce reportage
une dame, le patron, la patronne,
qui donne beaucoup d'elle-même
pour accompagner ces personnes
en situation de handicap.
Tous les patrons
peuvent faire de même ?
C'est pas une implication
qui est très importante
dans une entreprise,
d'avoir ces personnes handicapées ?
-Ce sujet-là,
c'est l'affaire de la société,
de l'Etat, bien sûr,
de la ministre que je suis,
mais également
des chefs d'entreprise,
des collectivités.
Je fais en sorte de travailler
intelligemment également
avec mes collègues ministres,
j'ai un portefeuille
interministériel.
Il faut faire avancer
la question de l'insertion
professionnelle
avec M. Dussopt, l'école inclusive
chez les tout-petits,
parce qu'il faut faire en sorte
que les enfants en situation
de handicap puissent fréquenter
l'école de la République,
et on a augmenté,
car on a 430 000 enfants
en situation de handicap,
qui fréquentent l'école.
-Avec des problèmes
pour recruter ces AESH,
qui accompagnent ces enfants.
-Je l'entends, mais il faut aussi
regarder le verre à moitié plein,
si je puis me permettre
cette expression, car en 2017,
quand nous sommes arrivés
aux commandes,
il y avait 49 000 AESH.
49 000, avec un statut précaire,
qu'on a aujourd'hui renforcé
et revalorisé,
et aujourd'hui,
elles sont 132 000.
Aujourd'hui, elles sont 132 000.
-Est-ce qu'il y a une solution
pour chaque enfant ?
-Certains enfants restent
sur le carreau,
c'est pourquoi le président
de la République a, dans le cadre
de la conférence du handicap
qui s'est tenue en avril,
annoncé
des solutions pour répondre
au mieux aux attentes
des personnes.
Là, j'insiste, car c'est important.
J'ai été enseignante
et j'ai été confrontée
à des apprentis
en situation de handicap,
et les enseignants...
Face à un enfant handicapé,
ils ne savent parfois pas faire.
On ne sait pas forcément prendre
le sujet à bras le corps.
Il faut passer par de la formation
et faire en sorte
de faire rentrer
le secteur médico-social
au sein de l'école de la République.
C'est le travail que nous mènerons
à partir de 2024
pour venir en soutien
aux équipes éducatives
et pédagogiques.
Les enseignants sont prêts.
Si on vient en appui,
il n'y a aucun souci.
Rendez-vous compte,
j'illustre quand même
avec un exemple.
Quand un enfant, demain,
pourra voir son ergothérapeute,
son psychologue, son orthophoniste
au sein de l'école de la République,
vous évitez déjà pour cet enfant
plusieurs transports.
Vous soulagez également les parents,
qui sont parfois en détresse,
car eux aussi doivent
concilier la vie de cet enfant
et la vie professionnelle.
Ce sont souvent des mères seules
qui sont confrontées
à cette situation
et qui sont parfois obligées
d'arrêter de travailler.
Je pense qu'il y a là
de nouvelles attentes,
un nouveau défi,
et je mettrai toute mon énergie,
avec le ministre Attal,
qui est vraiment
prêt à travailler main dans la main
pour faire avancer cette cause.
-Il y a un obstacle,
j'ai demandé à Hélène Bonduelle
qui a mené l'enquête,
cette société n'est pas rentable.
Il y a un obstacle
dans la tête des patrons,
qui pensent que monter une boîte
avec des handicapés,
ce n'est pas rentable.
C'est un tabou
à faire sauter ?
C'est compliqué à expliquer
qu'on peut être rentables ?
-Ils sont productifs,
en fait.
-Bien sûr.
On pose souvent la question,
mais il y a des aides pour compenser
la baisse de productivité.
L'Etat est au rendez-vous.
Il faut accompagner
les personnes handicapées
dans le milieu professionnel,
parce qu'in fine,
ils vont être aussi
à la charge de la société.
C'est l'affaire de tous.
C'est pourquoi l'Etat prend sa part,
les collectivités
doivent prendre la leur.
Le sujet du handicap
concerne également
les départements,
qui ont la compétence
des personnes
en situation de handicap,
et le monde économique.
-Il y a encore des freins
qu'il faut lever ?
-Oui.
-C'est psychologique ?
-Les choses
changent et nous aurons
un bel événement
avec les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques.
Je pense que cet événement
sera un événement très fort.
Il faut en profiter pour, déjà,
soutenir nos athlètes
paralympiques et faire en sorte
qu'ils soient capables
de belles choses, de se dépasser,
et de belles réussites.
Je fais confiance à ces Jeux
pour faire en sorte
que le regard change
sur le handicap.
-Il y a aussi le DuoDay,
où on voit une personne
avec une autre personne handicapée.
C'est devenu un événement annuel
auquel beaucoup d'entreprises
adhèrent.
-Oui, vraiment.
J'ai fait une réunion là-dessus.
Généralement,
on a plus de demandes d'entreprises
que de personnes
en situation de handicap.
On essaye de se manifester
et de faire de la publicité
sur ce DuoDay en demandant
aux personnes en situation
de handicap de venir.
Cela permet à des jeunes
de trouver un stage, un emploi.
-Il ne faut pas
que ça reste une journée.
-Voilà, et 23 % des personnes
qui sont passées
par le DuoDay,
qui est un événement
très fort, arrivent à rebondir
par le biais
d'un stage ou d'un emploi,
donc c'est formidable,
et je remercie
les chefs d'entreprise,
les collectivités aussi.
Mon ministère sera mobilisé
et je recevrai
des personnes handicapées
dans mon ministère.
-On vous offre
ce chocolat éthique
et très bien calibré.
-Excellent.
-Coup de chapeau à Nadine Abondo,
qui est une femme remarquable,
et un mot,
parce que ces handicapés fabriquent
cet excellent chocolat.
Vous êtes chocolat, vous ?
-J'aime toutes les douceurs.
Vous avez compris, voilà.
Je promets à cette dame,
que je félicite...
-Elle a été reçue
par le président.
-J'irai la voir.
J'irai la voir.
-Le rendez-vous est pris.
Vous avez été présidente
de la commission
des affaires sociales,
vous êtes attentive aux problèmes
des Français pour se nourrir.
Une personne sur cinq
ne mange pas à sa faim,
selon le Secours populaire.
On met les pieds dans le plat.
20 à 30 % des Français éprouvent
des difficultés à se nourrir
trois fois par jour,
selon les études.
C'est le cas d'Amina,
dont la retraite
ne lui permet pas
de manger à sa faim.
Chaque jour, il faut faire des choix
ou se contenter de peu.
On l'a accompagnée
dans son quotidien.
-C'est devenu une habitude.
Plusieurs fois par semaine,
Amina se rend
chez le primeur
en quête de produits.
-Oui, c'est là.
-Dans ce cageot,
des fruits et légumes
un peu abîmés, tous à 1 euro.
-Je prends ça.
Je prends une salade.
Il y a des figues,
je vais les prendre.
Ca me permet de manger des légumes
et des fruits frais.
Je ne peux pas me le permettre,
à leur prix d'origine.
-Verdict à la caisse :
5 euros seulement pour le tout.
-Sinon, les figues sont à 6 euros.
-Une belle économie.
Amina a dû faire une croix
sur les produits les plus chers :
la viande, pas plus d'une
à deux fois par semaine, et encore.
-On mange pas beaucoup de boeuf,
ça prend trop de temps à cuire.
Ca va consommer
beaucoup plus de gaz.
-Son seul petit plaisir...
-A la fin du mois,
quand je touche la retraite,
je me permets d'acheter
un peu de poisson, voilà.
-Un quotidien à l'euro près.
-Sur 869 euros,
je dois payer 422 euros de loyer,
50 euros,
à peu près,
pour Internet.
Pour l'électricité
et le gaz, j'ai 76 euros.
-Amina ne touche
qu'une faible pension
pour une retraite anticipée
à cause de son handicap.
Elle a pourtant longtemps travaillé.
-35 ans. Ce n'est pas normal.
Ce n'est pas normal,
pour 35 ans de travail,
que je ne touche que ça.
-En une journée,
elle ne mange qu'un seul repas,
en plus d'un petit-déjeuner frugal :
deux biscottes
ou deux tranches de brioche.
-Deux, pas plus. Et le café.
-L'après-midi est bien avancée
au moment de préparer
l'unique repas à partir de produits
bruts, source d'économies.
-Ca revient moins cher
et vous savez
ce que vous mangez, aussi.
-En fin de mois,
elle est parfois contrainte
de s'endetter auprès des commerçants
pour de la nourriture.
-Je prends des choses à crédit.
-Une situation difficile à vivre.
-Vous vous sentez humiliée.
C'est la première fois de ma vie
que je me plains
de ces augmentations.
-Une vie au jour le jour
où manger à sa faim
n'a plus rien d'évident.
-Les chiffres sont effarants.
Amina n'est pas la seule
dans ce cas, 20 à 30 % des Français
ont des difficultés à se nourrir
trois fois par jour, 15 % déclarent
ne plus pouvoir le faire.
Comment c'est possible,
dans la 7e puissance mondiale ?
-Bien sûr,
c'est extrêmement compliqué.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés
à une inflation très importante,
très dure, qui touche la France
et de nombreux pays dans le monde,
y compris d'ailleurs en Europe.
Le gouvernement,
au regard de cette crise,
s'est fortement mobilisé
pour essayer d'atténuer le choc,
notamment sur le carburant,
sur l'énergie.
-Le bouclier tarifaire
pour l'électricité
va jusqu'en décembre.
Il faudra le prolonger ?
-Il faut voir.
En tout cas, Elisabeth Borne,
la Première ministre,
et le gouvernement
sont mobilisés
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat.
Je rappelle qu'en 2017,
nous avions été élus
sur cette question
du pouvoir d'achat.
-On voit que ça s'est aggravé
avec l'inflation,
mais il y a une précarisation
qui gagne au-delà des classes
modestes.
-Tout à fait.
Et elle était inattendue,
cette inflation.
On fait face à un choc terrible.
Mais il va y avoir
un projet de loi
soutenu par Bruno Le Maire
sur comment lutter
contre l'inflation,
sur cette question-là.
-Il y aura
les renégociations commerciales.
-Oui, mais...
-Ca va faire baisser les prix ?
Ca a du mal à baisser.
Ca monte vite.
-Edouard Leclerc a dit que ceux
qui pensaient que les prix
allaient baisser d'ici Noël,
il le dit avec cynisme,
les prix ne baisseront pas.
Les chocolats, ça ne baissera pas.
Ca ne montera pas plus,
mais ça ne baissera pas.
-Le ministre
est pleinement mobilisé,
Bruno Le Maire,
sur cette question-là.
Il va réunir les industriels,
les producteurs,
les distributeurs,
pour faire en sorte
que les prix baissent.
On va voir si cet accord
aboutit, en tout cas,
je l'espère.
Il en va aussi de l'intérêt général.
Cette question est majeure,
les Français sont en attente.
-On dit à gauche
qu'il faut réguler les prix,
revenir à une économie
plus administrée.
-Oui, mais nous sommes
dans une économie de marché,
c'est très difficile
de pouvoir réguler,
mais chacun doit prendre sa part
de responsabilité.
J'en appelle aux industriels
de prendre leur part
et d'être responsables.
-De la grande distribution ?
-Oui, bien sûr,
le temps de passer
ce cap difficile.
-Ils ont le panier anti-inflation.
-Justement, ce projet de loi
vise notamment tous les produits
du quotidien,
donc j'espère qu'il aboutira.
Le projet de loi va être voté.
Si on peut avoir un accord,
c'est mieux.
-Vous leur dites
qu'il faut rogner sur les marges
et faire un effort ?
-Bien sûr, on leur dit.
L'Etat est pleinement mobilisé
et a mis les moyens sur la table
sur l'énergie,
sur le carburant, et donc,
j'attends des industriels
et des distributeurs
un effort là-dessus.
-Vous les croyez
quand ils disent
qu'ils sont à l'os ?
Ou ils privilégient leurs marges ?
-Je pense que...
Leurs marges, leurs actionnaires,
je pense qu'il y a de l'argent
et que cet argent peut être,
j'allais dire,
redistribué différemment.
-On avait parlé
d'un chèque alimentation,
qui n'a finalement pas vu le jour.
Vous pensez qu'il faut le remettre
au goût du jour ?
-On verra en fonction
du projet de loi qui a été présenté
le 27 septembre et qui arrive
dans l'hémicycle en octobre,
comment le débat va aboutir
et quelles vont être,
bien sûr, les réponses.
Encore une fois,
il y aura probablement,
suite au travail parlementaire,
des propositions de faites.
-On voit aussi,
c'est le cas d'Amina,
que les fins de mois sont dures.
La fin de mois arrive tôt.
20 % des gens vivent à découvert.
Faut-il inciter les entreprises
à augmenter les salaires ?
-Bien sûr.
-Ca crée cette spirale.
-On constate quand même aujourd'hui
que la situation économique du pays,
les clignotants économiques
sont au vert.
Les entreprises, en effet,
font des bénéfices et de la marge.
Simplement, avec cette problématique
de recrutement,
aujourd'hui,
beaucoup d'entreprises,
sur le terrain, me disent :
"Madame la ministre,
on ne trouve personne.
"J'ai besoin dans le bâtiment,
"dans la menuiserie,
dans la restauration,
"dans le milieu sanitaire."
On cherche du monde.
Dans le privé,
les salaires ont augmenté.
Face à ce problème de recrutement,
les chefs d'entreprise
sont obligés de revoir les salaires
et les augmentent.
Il y a donc cette dynamique.
Profitons de cette dynamique.
Les entreprises peuvent en effet
faire un effort.
Pour autant, j'entends souvent
qu'il faut taxer.
Ca n'est peut-être pas la solution.
-C'est pas le but du gouvernement.
-Non, même si je reste...
Je pense sincèrement
qu'elles peuvent faire un effort.
-On va à présent passer au dessert.
C'est Le péché mignon.
-Voici venu le temps du sucré,
Brigitte, avec une île flottante.
Je me dis, Fadila Khattabi,
que vous souhaitiez des oeufs
à la neige, car aujourd'hui,
la confusion est dans les esprits,
mais ce sont
deux desserts différents.
A l'origine, l'île flottante
est inventée à la fin du 19e siècle
par le chef Auguste Escoffier.
Il s'agit de tranches de génoise,
de biscuit
ou de brioche imbibées de liqueur
et séparées par de l'abricot.
Ca n'a donc rien à voir.
L'ensemble était servi
avec de la crème anglaise
ou une purée de fruits rouges.
Les oeufs à la neige sont des blancs
pochés sur une crème anglaise.
Ce sont donc des oeufs à la neige
qu'on dégustera.
Ca ne vous embête pas ?
-Pas du tout.
J'aime beaucoup la crème anglaise.
C'est un clin d'oeil,
j'ai vécu à Manchester
dans le cadre de mes études,
j'y étais professeure dans un lycée.
Il est vrai
que la cuisine anglaise...
Voilà, c'est compliqué.
Par contre, j'aimais beaucoup
certains desserts.
-Certains, oui.
-Voilà.
J'aime la crème anglaise
et j'aime aussi beaucoup,
j'aurais pu vous le demander,
un cheesecake.
J'adore ça.
Ce sont de bons desserts.
-Vous avez appris
la vraie recette
de la crème anglaise ?
-J'avoue que je n'en ai jamais fait.
-Vous n'en faites pas ?
-C'est facile.
-Je la mange au restaurant,
ils la préparent très bien.
-Vous pouvez la goûter
pour nous dire
si ça vous rappelle
vos années en Angleterre
et à Manchester.
-Ah... Elle est meilleure.
-Meilleure qu'en Angleterre,
évidemment.
-Très bonne.
-Les oeufs sont bien pochés.
Je ne sais pas
s'ils sont pochés au four.
Quand on cuit les blancs,
on peut le faire au four
ou sur de l'eau bouillante
ou du lait bouillant.
L'eau bouillante,
quand elle bout
à 100 degrés,
elle fait des oeufs plus fermes.
C'est très bon.
La crème anglaise
a été inventée par les Anglais ?
-Je ne suis pas certaine.
-En tout cas, franchement,
elle est excellente.
-Alors, on va terminer
cette émission
en musique, comme à chaque fois.
Vous avez choisi cette chanson,
on l'écoute,
et vous nous expliquerez
votre choix.
"Mozart l'Egyptien : Lamma bada
yatathenna", Milen Natchev
...
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-C'est Mozart revisité,
comme ma cuisine.
J'aime beaucoup Mozart.
C'est "Mozart l'Egyptien".
C'est le mélange des deux cultures,
l'Orient et l'Occident,
et je trouve
que la culture rapproche
les humains
et c'est un clin d'oeil, voilà.
-La boucle est bouclée.
-Bien sûr, voilà.
C'est toute cette richesse humaine
qu'il faut savoir partager.
-Merci, Fadila Khattabi,
d'avoir partagé votre richesse
avec nous à table.
Merci à Chez Françoise,
qui nous a cuisiné
ces très bons plats.
Merci à vous tous
de nous suivre chaque semaine
et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine
dans "Politiques, à table !"
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...